so I've always think of calcium as a
slightly British element because the
White Cliffs of Dover are made from
calcium carbonate chalk calcium is one
of the group two or alkaline earth
elements it's got an atomic number of
about of twenty it's calcium itself is a
metal but people that most commonly see
it as is compounds it's a relatively
soft sort of silvery metal which I can
actually show you this is quite an old
sample of calcium okay so it's a bit
tarnished calcium is very very reactive
so it quickly forms a layer so you can
see it's kind of shiny by there it
quickly forms a layer of sort of oxides
and nitrides in the end which is it what
this calcium has done here so many of
you will have come across calcium
sulfate which is used at chalk and
school nowadays people use drain markers
and things but they're still we
sometimes use chalk on blackboards the
phrase in the limelight which I'm sure
you've heard of you know being in
meaning television the phrase in the
limelight actually comes from the fact
that they used to use calcium oxide and
they used to aim a very hot flame in it
make it kind of ins of beak and essent
and that's how the theatres and sort of
musicals used to be lit so when you're
in the limelight you literally were in
the light of line funnily enough we use
electricity now for it for lighting all
these sorts of things but the phrase
still lasts which is quite nice and the
compound of calcium and carbon so called
calcium carbide reacts with water to
produce acetylene a very reactive
compound of carbon which burns with a
bright light and in the early days of
motoring and cycling people use calcium
carbide lights in which they had some of
this powdered calcium carbide at the
bottom of the lamp and water dripped
slowly on it to produce a gas which
burnt and gave a beam which was not
nearly as bright of one of our current
headlights but was still bright enough
to get around and actually sort of
expanded in the chemistry of this
compound that this element I think which
is your slightly misunderstood and
sometimes thought would be in a bit
boring but I don't it's it's not boring
I think it'll have a great chemistry and
hopefully very useful well as chemists
like nothing like to see spectacular
things some things some things do you
know do do cool things I mean the
transition metals change color you know
which is all you know you have all these
nice colors of the transition metals
but the things that are sort of in the
main group which I mean sort of the
s-block so the ones on the left and the
p-block and the ones on the right don't
tend to form very colored compounds it's
a particular thing to the transition
metals most of the time so they don't do
much much in the way of color change
boring removes calcium compounds of
white
I mean you okay your bones your teeth or
why can't they really but still we can
do you know interesting chemistry of
them you know can we make calcium
compounds that could be used as its
reaction catalysts which would be great
because calcium is a cheap pretty benign
as well
so it would be an ideal catalyst
compared to sort of lot they're
expensive transition metals